we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P our friend the Eggman
called in the Eggman as you may know is
a Jewish gentleman from a rural New York
State he is reporting an anti-semitic
incident as he was considering buying a
used car
let's listen to the Eggman story
hi Dave I test drove a car that I was
going to buy with a private seller
during the test drive the guy made
anti-submitted comments and an
anti-lgbtq comments really disgusting
when we finished the test drive I told
him in the Wegmans parking lot to his
face the things he said were vile and
disgusting and I would never buy a car
from him he just stared at me said
nothing I drove away he pulled up next
to me the traffic light spit in my face
in the window cursed me out anti-semitic
stuff anti-lgbtq yelled at me a bunch of
spit in my window I kind of chased them
down but the dude was very scared he
drove over curved evaded me that was
definitely a hate crime right Dave
should I call the police and report it I
do have his actual name from Facebook
Marketplace or should I just blow it off
because that's how things are in Western
New York
Shalom well Shalom to the Eggman so
here's my thought on this I am not a
lawyer nor a police officer the ic2
possible crimes here
spitting I guess through that was one
hell of a loogie spitting through out
his window and into the eggman's window
that's that's a lot but that seems like
that would be a crime and then I don't
know if this is the guy driving over the
curb in an erratic attempt to get away
from the Eggman that maybe is a crime I
don't know if the Eggman was chasing
this guy in his car it's possible the
Eggman committed some crime I don't I
don't know about that so listen I'm
Gonna Leave This one to the audience
should the Eggman report this to the
police and let them handle it or not I
want to hear from you leave a comment on
YouTube maybe make a post on the
subreddit people can have a discussion
that is a hell of a situation hell of a
situation I've been in a lot of
anti-Semitic situations but uh none none
quite like that but glad that the Eggman
is safe on today's bonus show oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad Cornell West has
announced that he is running for
president under the People's Party
umbrella a party that is not on the
ballot they have no ballot it access in
any state will be very interesting
discussion on the bonus show I'm sure
YouTube has altered its policy to allow
false claims about past U.S presidential
elections what does this mean and do
they really mean it and lastly Robert
Hansen arguably the most damaging FBI
spy in history has been found dead in
his prison cell I know quite a bit about
Robert Hansen we actually interviewed on
this program uh the FBI agent who was
tasked with catching Robert Hansen
played by Ryan Phillippe eventually in
the movie adaptation of that story a
very interesting situation uh an
incredible story and we will discuss it
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com it's very cheap folks and
it's our number one source of funding I
hope to see you on the bonus show in a
few minutes